la croyait morte et enterrée cette
réforme avait disparu de notre horizon à
cause du kobe 19 et nous pensions
pouvoir en réchapper mais c'était sans
compter sur la pugnacité des manuels
maccoyii son obsession à faire passer la
réforme des retraites d'ici mai 2022
voilà des mois que je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs d'arte et france que
cette réforme est l'objectif cardinal d'
emmanuel macron depuis le début de son
quinquennat
on se rappellera les manifestations
importantes d'isf en 2019 pour se poser
la réforme et la difficulté de la
majorité présidentielle a expliqué les
bienfaits rappelez-vous magali cette
réforme dans une sorte de soucoupe
choucroute médiatique confondante
alors voilà notre cher président depuis
le lot pour la première étape de tour de
france nous annoncer la bonne nouvelle
il ya quelques jours la réforme des
retraites va revenir et pas question de
faiblir même si cela lui coûte sa
réélection car emmanuel macron n'en
démord pas il faut réformer le pays dans
les grandes largeurs coûte que coûte
souvenez-vous est aujourd'hui le chef de
l'état ragaillardi par les beaux jours
et la levée des restrictions sanitaires
ne veut pas faire sans qu emmanuel
macron applique son programme c'est son
droit le plus absolu
mais ce qui me gêne affreusement magali
c'est le fait de dissimuler aux français
que ces réformes qui vend d'ailleurs
intacte y profondément leur existence
pour de longues journées sont le fait de
la soumission à l'ordo libéralisme
bruxellois en avril dernier
bruno le maire notre cher ministre de
l'économie déclaré chez nos confrères du
figaro que je cite une que la réforme
des retraites n'est pas une exigence de
bruxelles mais une nécessité
pourtant la réforme est bien mentionné
en pointillés dans le programme
stabilité budgétaire au printemps
dernier mais absolument rien n'a filtré
dans le communiqué du conseil des
ministres ni écouter bien dans le résumé
du programme de stabilité envoyé à la
presse selon nos confrères du canard
enchaîné daté d'hier
emmanuel macron vérité doit cette vérité
aux français car l'accélération cette
réforme est soumise au plan de relance
européen dans lequel la france est très
très largement perdante et a été
notamment signé contre l'intérêt des
français la presse mainstream qui
devrait mettre en exergue ce lien fait
silence radio absolu sur l'arrière cour
des réformes d'emmanuel macron alors ne
pas faire le lien entre la réforme des
retraites et le diktat européen est au
mieux un oubli au pire une omission
coupable il y en a vu ce que cela
donnait en grains
souvenez vous en 2015 une belle moussaka
d'austérité avec son velouté de pauvreté
cuisine et amoureusement par la troïka
magali